when you implement back-propagation you
find out that they test called gradient
checking they can really help you make
sure that your implementation of back
prop is correct because sometimes you
write all these equations is just not a
hundred potential if you got all the
details right it into any bank
obligation so in order to build up to
gradient checking let's first talk about
how to numerically approximate
computations of gradients and in the
next video we'll talk about how you can
imprint gradient checking to make sure
the implementation of back prop is
correct so let's take the function f and
we plot it here remember this is a f of
theta equals theta two and let's again
start off with some value of theta let's
say theta equals one now instead of just
nudging theta to the right to get theta
plus epsilon we're going to nudge it to
the right and nudge it to the left to
get theta minus epsilon as well as theta
plus epsilon so this is one this is one
point oh one this is 0.99 where we gain
epsilon this same as before the 0.01 it
turns out that rather than taking this
little triangle and computing the height
over the width you can get a much better
estimate of the gradient if you take
this point FS a the minus F 1 and this
point and you instead compute the height
over width of this bigger triangle so
for technical reasons which I won't go
into the height over width of this
bigger green triangle gives you much
better approximation to the derivative
at theta everyone you know sort of in
for taking just this little triangle in
the upper right is as if you have two
triangles right this one on the upper
right and this one on the lower left and
you're kind of taking both of them into
account by using this bigger being
triangle so rather than a one-sided
difference it's just a two sided
difference so let's work on the map this
point here is f of theta plus epsilon
this point here is f of theta minus
epsilon so
this big green triangle is f of theta
plus epsilon minus f of theta minus
epsilon and the other width you know
this is one epsilon this is two epsilon
so the width of this green triangle is 2
Epsilon
so the height of it was going to be
first the height so that's F of theta
plus epsilon minus F of theta minus
epsilon divided by the width so that was
2 Epsilon we should work on down here
and this should hopefully be close to G
of theta so plugging the values remember
f of theta is Theta 2 so this is theta
plus epsilon this 1.01 so take the cube
of that minus 0.99 take the tube of that
divide it by 2 times 0.01 seen for you
to pause the video and solve this in a
calculator you should get that this is
three point zero zero zero one whereas
from the previous slide we saw that G of
theta this was V theta squared so when
theta equals one this is so these two
values are actually very close to each
other the approximation error is on now
0.0001 whereas on the previous slide
we're taking the one side the difference
just beta and theta plus epsilon we had
gotten three point zero three zero one
and so the approximation error when zero
point zero three are involved in 0.0001
but so with this two-sided difference
way of approximating the derivative you
find that this is extremely close to
three and so this gives you you know
much greater confidence that G of theta
is a probably a correct implementation
of the derivative of F when you use this
method for gradient checking and back
propagation this turns out to run twice
as slow as you would use a one-sided
difference it turns out that in practice
I think it's worth it to use this on a
method because it's just much more
accurate um a little bit of optional
theory for those of you they're a little
bit more familiar of calculus it turns
out that and is okay if you don't get
what
about to say here that turns out that
the formal definition of the derivative
is for very small values of s long is as
a theta plus epsilon minus f of theta
minus epsilon over 2 Epsilon and the
formal definition of the derivative is
in the limit of exactly that formula on
the right as epsilon goes to 0 and the
definition of a limit is something that
you learn if you take a calculus class
but I won't go into that here and it
turns out that for a nonzero value of
Epsilon
you can show that the error of this
approximation is on the order of epsilon
squared
and remember epsilon is very small
number so the epsilon is you know 0.01
which it is here then epsilon squared is
0.0001 the Big O notation means the
error is actually some constant times
this but this is actually exactly our
approximation error so the big old
constant happened to be 1 whereas in
contrast we were to use this formula the
other one then the error is on the order
of Epsilon and again when epsilon is a
number less than 1 then epsilon is
actually much bigger than epsilon
squared which is why this one right here
is actually much less accurate
approximation then this formula on the
Left which is why when do ingredient
checking we rather uses two sided
difference when you compute f of theta
plus epsilon minus f of theta minus
epsilon and then divide by two epsilon
rather than this one-sided difference
which is less accurate if you didn't
understand my last few comments all of
these things down here don't worry about
it
that's really more for those of you
there have been more familiar with
calculus and with numerical
approximations but the takeaway is that
this two sides a difference longer is
much more accurate and so that's what
we're going to use what we do gradient
checking in the next video so you've
seen how by taking a two sided
difference you can numerically verify
whether or not a function G G of theta
that someone else gives you is a correct
implementation of the derivative of the
function f let's now see how we can use
this to verify whether or not your back
propagation implementation is correct or
if you know there might be a bug in
there that you need to go in and
he's old